quel est le nom et prénom du personnage
d'eva longoria dans la série desperate
housewife je dirais la réponse à
gabrielle solis
[Applaudissements]
voici la deuxième quels diplômes obtenus
et va à l'université de los angeles
s'il vous plaît allez avocate avocate et
non elle a un diplôme de kinésiologie
alors là à les y ait un genou est lourd
mais le lourd le lourd qui fait genre
recettes le mec qui fait genre et titube
studio acton vale attention voici la
dernière
quelle est la spécialité que cuisine le
mieux et va le bois brut on ne sait quoi
eva guacamole ouakam hall whack a mole
et la souplesse de zakaria les deux
c'est vrai il paraît que vous faites le
meilleur guacamole du monde parce qu'on
m'a dit forcément c'est bon on s'en fout
c'est perdu eva mais la fracasser le
faites moi plaisir
oh là là quelle nuit écoulée lors eva
longoria merci d'état
[Musique]